The Bachelor begins filming some of
Cullen's women are revealed and Jordan
and Jenna are deep in forensic analysis
it's time for roses and roasts hey you
guys we are back oh hello everybody i'm
lauren zima and yes there is no current
season of a bachelor show airing but I
missed you guys and big news we will be
back with videos every single week until
January when the new season of The
Bachelor premieres and thank you all so
much for your suggestions on how to keep
roses in rows a-going still between the
seasons so what we're gonna do is bring
you bachelor news big interviews and
some really fun pieces where we look
back at some of our favorite moments
from the shows so let us know what you
guys want to see we're going to start
out with the most Awkward kisses ever
let me know which kisses you have felt
have been the most awkward in the
history of the series in the comments
below
they will make it into our video and
again any other ideas you guys have
maybe best breakups
maybe best in the worst way breakups let
me know now let's catch up on bachelor
nation news yes we won't get the new
season until January but you guys Colton
has already begun filming in fact a
source tells me that this show just
wrapped filming and it Los Angeles and
is heading on the road so what do we
know
well of course head over to reality
Steve's Twitter if you like spoilers
because he is posting some of the women
some of the dates shockingly helicopters
have been involved shockingly concerts
have been involved what do you guys
think of what we're seeing so far and do
you like reading the spoilers or do you
want to wait until everything happens on
television let me know let me know let
me know I don't know I think in the age
of social media it's impossible for this
stuff to not get out people just pull
out that phone and snap a picture you
know look I pretend that the paparazzi
are constantly following me in my head
oh one thing I forgot to mention I told
you to be meeting three women but I
didn't tell you how it's time to play
know or go out in the public for all to
see was Colden on Ellen he went on The
Ellen Show and Matt three of his women
and what did we think of this it was
awkward okay yeah it was I just have to
say Colton's very sweet but it was a
little awkward I mean first we had a a
thing her name was Sydney and she
screwed up like the most basic oldest
pick-up line in the book my hi Colton
did you just fall from heaven or are you
an angel I don't know actually now I
forgot it what's that pickup line about
if you're a fish did it hurt when you
fell from heaven she screwed up that
pickup line that I just screwed up crap
I can't blame him Sydney did it hurt
when you fell from heaven what do you
think is the most attractive thing about
Colton well I have seven dogs so
definitely that he loves dogs one girl
was talking about how she had all those
dogs on that horse farm they are no
horse farm my mom's horse farm what what
what where do you live what's happening
ooh
I think we'd go to another girl was
asked what kind of date she'd want to go
on with Colton and she said quote
something with food like something with
do better ladies we got to do better I
know we're nervous I know we're on Allen
but the bachelor is a big show and
you're gonna be on it then we we
finished off the awkwardness with a
controversy about what a golden birthday
is
have you had your golden birthday yet
this is my golden birthday this year
oh this year yeah no but wherever you 27
he says I'm not sure Colton knows I'm
not sure that girl knew of these three
what do you guys think did any of them
seem like a viable candidate for Colton
I felt the dog girl cuz at least that
was a real connection this my big lap
dog cuz if we know anything about Colton
it's that he loves dogs he has a line of
clothing out guys about how much he
loves dogs now that's ready already has
a line of clothing let me know what you
think of that me gonna buy anything let
me know
anyway Colton also went on camel you are
a virgin yes sir I'm not even get into
that more virginity stuff you know I'm
predicting this right now it's gonna
become a thing that Colton gets sick of
talking about his virginity and
interviews but that first promo guys put
it on the books my prediction is that
first fella for his season he's gonna be
all about the fact that he's a virgin
and that's okay I'm here for it and I'm
excited how are you feeling about
coldness bachelor at this point are you
stoked for it do you think it's gonna be
a good season has your mind changed at
all have you recovered from the Jason
Blake loss it's okay and by the way like
we said we'll still be bringing you
bachelor interviews oh my gosh I talked
to all of these people these bachelor
people ad nauseam backstage at
iHeartRadio in Las Vegas the full
interviews are up at et online calm but
here's a quick teaser of drama here you
watch Colton season of course to be a
dumpster fire of course they're gonna
watch Colton for bachelor not my
bachelor did the show eat you guys alone
yeah
destroyed me I've never been the same
but I never will be the same my message
for : have fun whether they enjoy the
journey and find someone that is perfect
for you can't wait to meet her
if there's some that you think might be
a good fit for Blake and I don't forget
so let's talk bachelor news you can
booze over jordan and jenna everybody
Wow the saga continues I just want to
read aloud if you don't know what's
going on of course it came out unreality
Steve alleged text messages about Jenna
allegedly cheating on Jordan and she is
sort of now saying I believe hard to
tell that she did not so we'll pull it
up for you it's a picture of a phone
it's a sparkly gold phone case I used to
have this phone case I got it at
Marshall's and the phone seems to be
plugged into a computer from 1994 and it
says extraction in progress because this
is a scene from an Harrison Ford movie
in the 90s that's a lot of personal data
up there that if true probably shouldn't
be posted on social media so Jana says
the results from the forensic analysis
are in and I feel compelled to share
them with Jordan before anywhere else so
I guess that means we're not gonna find
anything out but I will say that she
says quote I will not be silenced and
she continues to talk and do not drink
every time Jenna says forensic analysis
don't do it because she has more
instagrams hmm
so then we get another one and her
eyebrows are intense and Jenna says
obviously like I already knew the
forensic analysis of my electronic
devices what year is it and iCloud
account prove that the fraudulent text
message is posted by reality Steve we're
not mine interesting use of quotes there
is growing and compelling evidence
pointing to who was behind this attack
on me and it is very sad given the legal
issues and ongoing investigation so much
char again I am delaying posting the
forensic data
until the investigation is fully
completed one thing is for sure there is
a huge twist and it is killing me
keeping it quiet while the investigation
right while the investigation is
completed you will be hearing more about
this in the next few weeks and I'm going
to attempt to start moving on with my
life hashtag justice served cold
Wow Wow Wow I don't know what any of
that means I don't what are we analyzing
in our text messages and I'm not saying
whether Jenna cheated on Jordan or
didn't I just don't understand what
forensic analysis of text messages that
you seemingly are alleging that you
didn't send would be derived from your
phone like if she's saying that that
that would this was an attack and I
think she's saying that this was an
attack and she seems to allegedly be
saying that the texts were fake how are
you gonna figure that out from your
phone if that if they aren't if they
weren't there if they're fabricated
they're not gonna be in that phone
what's in that phone what is the
forensic analysis of the forensic phone
data from 1994 to help us analyze all
this data forensic analysis legal expert
JC is here everybody we knew that we
could not get through a roses and rose'
without our man of the hour
JC as always you provide insight you
provide expertise you provide in-depth
forensic analysis today yes so my friend
dressed in your blazer wearing your
glasses can you explain to me what Jenna
means by forensic analysis well you have
to take a old Pacific Bell Telephone you
dial it up like that it takes a while
because cell phone numbers 10 digits and
all that stuff of course what do you
think
Jordan's mindset is right now Jordan
it's probably forgotten about all this
and moved ahead Jordan is probably
sitting pretty looking at all those
options come in all the television deals
come in right
I think I think he's doing fine JC you
have absolutely of course as an expert
hit the nail on the head because
everybody while jenna is instagramming
about forensic analysis jordan is
posting an ad for diff eyewear quote
every rose has its thorn but diff
eyewear helps me with the shade jordan a
round of applause for jordan juicy
you're so good at giving advice what
would you tell Jenna as she moves on
with her life what she says she intends
to do I would just say stop stoking the
flames with all this evidence-based
claims and all these Facebook hashtag
justice served cold rebuttals just let
it go move on you're still popular
people still love you people will love
Jordan that's it just move on just move
on hashtag just move on with JC Thank
You JC everyone cheers to Jenna and
Jordan I wish the best for both of them
and think that they're both just such a
treat I love you all more importantly
thank you for watching roses and Rose
day every weekend for telling us that
you wanted episodes in between the
seasons we again will be here every week
and we want to know what you want to see
tell us what some of your favorite
compilation videos that we should do are
should we look back at certain seasons
let me know in the meantime JC and I
will be here glass of rose in hand I'm
just taking it all that there is on the
interwebs bye
[Music]